all right uh
yeah that was the play of the day the
play of the year so far
the the the dolphins on the play called
boys you've probably seen that a time or
two over the last 12 to 15 hours they
took it from boise state fiesta bowl win
over oklahoma it was designed to be one
lateral right
and
when kenny stills flipped it devonte
parker parker's supposed to run with it
but
parker had kenyon drake with a head of
steam and rob gronkowski was on the
field and ryan tannehill told me after
the game that he was yelling pitch it
pitch it to parker parker did adam gase
on the sidelines was upset because as
designed parker's supposed to run right
the the ball they practice it every
other week in walk walk-through setting
and and and it worked and look
kudos to the dolphins for making it work
but i think the big takeaway for me
chris
the the the masters of situational
football yes right the new england
patriots yeah why in the hell is rob
gronkowski on the field when the
dolphins are nearly 70 yards away from
pdart and it's not going to be your
traditional hail mary throw yeah i think
that's the the big question and
something we don't see new england mess
up very much at all if if ever really
but i guess they were playing for the
hail mary
now i think that's where they messed up
though mike i mean how does bill
belichick do that right you've got a
theory about playing games in miami i
know i know does bill belichick fall
victim to the vacation yesterday
it gets the best of everybody there's
something about going down to miami and
getting in that hotel room you say that
all the time though and and and look the
pain i fall asleep all the time five or
six games in miami and these are not don
shula's dolphins we saw the bears fall
asleep there you know four or five weeks
ago too um but i i guess at the at the
end of the day they did make a mistake
it's just as far as maybe scouting ryan
tannehill that's where you would start
to go wait can he really throw the ball
70 plus yards to get it in the end zone
here apparently they thought he could i
know he's had his shoulder right i know
well that's what i'm saying so that's
where i would push back against the
patriots right now now they thought
obviously he could that's why they put
gronkowski in why it's not a josh gordon
in that instance who we've seen on the
field uh during these type of situations
already this year i think that is where
i was uh a little surprised that he
wasn't the guy there he is
is gronk the hedge is gronk the guy that
like okay we're gonna go middle ground
here because if it is a crazy play out
in in space that we think gronk can go
swallow the guy i mean even though he
couldn't i mean i i know your thought
but i'm also going with josh gordon's
faster than he is we know that so i know
that's and you know okay he's not as
tall as gronkowski but he's not far off
and i would think his vertical leap is
probably up there we saw him on the
field i believe it was the bears game
when they when the bears caught that
ball and everybody on new england stayed
on the ground i think the most
the weirdest thing to me though mike
more than anything is the fact that
devin mccourty wasn't on the field uh
and again it's this is odd that we're
even like being knit they're picking
away at the page but we wouldn't be
making these complaints of any other
team and i think it becomes more glaring
in a team that we always point to as the
the gold standard the platinum standard
right the titanium standard of
situational football that they screwed
it up multiple times yesterday that
wasn't the only one they screwed up at
the end of the half right right and and
we'll talk about the other problem but
let's let's let's make sure we exhaust
this completely i mean yeah they they
blew it we we say it with every other
coach and every other team and just
because the patriots have had such a
great run over the last 18 years when
they blow it number one it becomes more
significant and number two they deserve
to be called out like anybody else would
be yeah they do they certainly do and
it's just that much more shocking when
they do blow it but the devin mccourty
thing is what's like shocking to me
first of all devin mccourty arguably the
fastest guy on their defense right i
mean we saw the interception pick six he
had against the buffalo bills a few
weeks i think the net gen stack next gen
stats or whatever had him as the like
the fastest mile per hours we've seen
all year i i'm just shocked and he's a
great open field tackler i'm shocked he
wasn't one of the guys in the back end
there chasing him uh but really i think
going back to a great word i like to use
here lately that here comes the
microcosm of the day yes it was because
the patriots i'm glad you got it out of
the way early good good i just i wanted
to get it out there but the patriots
messed up things throughout that game
that we just don't ever see them mess up
and that was just one play that kind of
put the icing on the cake well and and
the mistake at the end of the second
half the patriots have the ball on the
miami two first half right right at the
end of the first half 14 seconds left no
timeouts they took the snap
tom brady gets sacked the clock runs out
yup
that that's not a patriots outcome
that's like and and 27 21 was the score
even if you get the field goal there
you're up nine points going to the
second half the rest and they get the
ball in the second half and they drive
down the field to miss the field goal so
those are the things like we're used to
seeing them make those six or ten point
swings or do something like that and
they miss those opportunities really to
at a chance there where they could have
really put miami in a tough spot to go
we're going in the half 30 to 21 you're
in deep trouble and we're getting the
ball is there an arrogance that creeps
in in that spot when you've got the ball
on the two with 14 seconds left that
you'll figure it out and they won't
you'll make it happen and they they
won't you're either going to get the
touchdown you know they're not going to
make a play yeah we'll have a problem
here if they make a play and sack tom
brady but they're not going to sack tom
brady in this spot we're going to we're
going gonna we're gonna win this play
they
hey the patriots can be arrogant there's
no doubt about that but they're usually
not arrogant with like this type of
situation what i find shocking here is
i almost feel like did they just think
brady knew the situation and never
communicated it to him you know what i
mean like because even brady got up like
he was like oh gosh wait we don't have a
timeout are you kidding me like almost
like i'm gonna just hey you've been
playing this 19 vacation time i don't
need to tell you
that we're no timeouts here you know to
throw the ball
miami vacation i just i just found that
to be an amazing moment for new england
who more times now we see score
touchdowns in that instance but uh
never or seldom see them miss the
opportunity
to at least stop the clock there get the
field goal and have that you know end of
the first half started the second half
run that they're so famous for you know
they weren't the only team leading a
division in the afc to lose three of the
four division leaders lost and that's
good news for the patriots now the bad
news is we felt like they were going to
slide into the number one seed
everything else is just details and they
still may yeah right and they need it
because at home this year they're 6-0
right on the road they are three and
four seeing the patriots below 500 in
anything is a stunner four losses on the
year all coming on the road they can't
afford to have to go on the road in the
postseason chris no they cannot there
certainly seem to be a team that's built
for you know home football or at least
ride that wave of energy that they get
at home uh
it is it's rare to see them play so bad
on the road throughout the year i mean
the jaguar game was underwhelming the
tennessee titan game was underwhelming
miami there were some good things they
did yesterday they made a lot of big
plays in the pass game they blocked two
punts but
we saw the their defense break yesterday
where we saw frank gore and drake and
everybody else had big plays throughout
the day which were things i certainly
did not expect so yeah there's obviously
some issues there on the road uh i you
know i don't know if there's anything
like one area of their game i'd say
slips up on the road it's just they kind
of underperform as a whole team they had
a chance yesterday to clinch their 10th
consecutive division title and they
likely still yes of course right
i don't see the patriots losing their
final three games and the dolphins
winning their final three games and the
dolphins leap frogging them but
yesterday's outcome was so stunning
and even though
tom brady was seven and nine
playing in miami and they had lost four
out of five like yeah but you know what
this time the patriots know i really
take it seriously i really thought so
yeah i'm with you i mean i just thought
this is they're gonna run the ball on
the miami dolphins they won't be able to
stop it i'd be shocked if the dolphins
can run the ball on them they'll become
one dimensional i mean that's really how
i saw the game kind of playing out and i
mean we started off the game with going
whoa there goes frank gore in a huge run
there goes the frank goren another huge
run next series was brandon bolden i
mean it was just unbelievable kind of
what
events took place yesterday in that game
there's a lot to say about the steelers
but yeah the most important thing moving
forward they host the patriots next week
and the steelers are coming off of three
straight losses the patriots have now
lost two out of five and the patriots
typically play the steelers well in
pittsburgh that is a huge game for
reasons different from last year last
year it was the precursor to
the supposed rematch and who's going to
have home field advantage this year the
steelers if they lose
they got the saints the following week
the steelers are suddenly you know the
patriots are on the verge of losing the
one seed the steelers are on the verge
of losing all seeds
they may be out right and and uh we got
a lot to talk about as it relates to the
steelers but
how loud will the cries in pittsburgh be
for dramatic change
if a team that finagled a six-game
winning streak and seemed to be destined
for great things in january ends up not
in the postseason at all yeah i would
think there would be big they're a big
big trouble in pittsburgh it'd be the
first time where i would actually if
they went through a bad stretch here at
the end of the season where they're in
the midst of a bad stretch but don't
finish strong i think it's the first
time where i would actually go into
offseason going ooh okay maybe my time
on tomlin's actually in trouble this
time around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports